(upbeat rock music)
- I've been told that there's no
spot for a woman in this sport.
I've been physically assaulted in the cage,
but I didn't let any of that stop me.
Sometimes the fight is
outside of the ring.
I'm Swayze Valentine, and I'm the
first and only cutwoman in MMA.
What we do is we wrap the fighters hands
before they fight and we take
care of them between rounds.
If there's any bleeding, we stop it;
if there's any swallowing, we take it away.
Pretty much the cutman
motto is to give them
that one round that they needed to win.
I saw my first live MMA fight, and
it was just such a cool experience, and I
wanted to be a part of that
arena as much as I could.
I talked to the promoter and
asked him what jobs there were.
He told me that my option
was to be a ring girl.
I had to wear the tiniest string bikini.
It was super uncomfortable to be wearing
that in front of all these people.
That was not a fit for me.
I saw the fighters getting
their hands wrapped,
and I immediately got butterflies
in my stomach and I knew that was what
I was supposed to be a part of.
I would drive sixty miles one way to gyms,
and I would voluntarily sit there
and wrap fighters hands for
their sparring sessions.
Just the sacrifice of doing it for so long
without getting any income out
of it was really, really hard.
I was a single mother of two young boys
and still trying to be a cutwoman.
Wrapping hands is more than just
putting gauze around a hand.
If you do not wrap a
fighters hands correctly
then their hands will break.
You need to wrap hundreds and hundreds
of hands to be considered great.
I'd wrap my kids hands; I'd wrap
my parents hands; I'd wrap my friend hands;
I would wrap as many hands
as I could possibly find.
It took me years to
feel like I got it down.
My first paying gig was WSOF,
World Series of Fighting in 2010.
After four years of doing it for free.
In 2014, I was added to
the roster of UFC cutmen.
UFC is the Ultimate Fighting Championship.
It is the most famous stage in the world.
It's like the Olympics of MMA.
And now I travel all over the world
being a cutwoman for the UFC.
Nice job!
During my journey of being a cutwoman
I had a lot of ups and downs.
My kids are a huge
reason why I do all this.
They can see me, you know, not giving up
and in the end hitting my goal,
and that's what carried me
through 10 years of it, you know?
It's just that desire inside of like,
just keep going, keep going.
I understand what the fighter has
to go through to get into the cage.
We both had to fight to
get our spot in the ring.